and curry is making a much-anticipated
return to television curry was with
NBC's Today Show for 15 years
she co-anchored from 2011 to 2012 before
a highly publicized break with the
broadcast curry left NBC in 2015 and
created her own production company her
new show on PBS is called will meet
again it follows people searching for
someone they lost to time in history
events that changed the world how did
you first see Gary Ferguson crazy
American cowboy people who changed each
other's lives there's nobody that had a
bigger impact on my life your I Francis
was standing up for you I need to see
her and it gets more urgent the older
and get Ann Curry is with us now only on
CBS this morning hi everybody welcome
it's great to have you back it's great
to see we're gonna talk a lot about your
show but I do think a lot of people want
to hear from you as well because this is
your first television interview and a
lot has changed in the television
landscape one morning television in the
last three months
our former co host Charlie Rose has left
someone you anchored with Matt Lauer has
left his broadcast what do you make of
this reckoning I think it's in general
overdue
we clearly are waking up to a reality
and injustice that has been occurring
for some time and I think it will
continue to occur until the glass
ceiling is finally broken this is about
power a power imbalance and where women
are not valued as much as men I'm not
talking about people being attracted to
other people I'm talking about people in
the workplace who are powerful who are
abusing that power and women and men are
suffering and I think the fact that
people are speaking out is important and
the fact that we are moving against this
imbalance of power is absolutely overdue
do you believe that Matt Lauer abused
his power you know I'm
trying to do a harm in these
conversations I can tell you that I I am
not surprised by the allegations what do
you mean by that and I mean that you're
not surprised because word things you
knew things what does that mean that
means that in you know I'm down walking
down that road I'm trying not to hurt
people and I know what it's like to be
publicly humiliated I never did anything
wrong to be publicly humiliated and and
I don't want to cause that kind of pain
to somebody else but I can say that I
because you're asking me a very direct
question I can say that I would be
surprised if many women did not
understand that there was a climate of
verbal harassment that existed I think
it would be surprising if someone said
that they didn't see that so it was a
verbal sexual all right let me stick
with it I'm sorry I just don't she just
said verbal sexual harassment was
pervasive yeah at NBC at the time anyway
you know III like again I I don't want a
boy I you know I don't want to cause
more pain but no I'm you were asking me
a very direct question I'm an honest
person I want to tell you that it was
yes period all right I was gonna to pick
up on the notion of power because in the
court of public opinion it was viewed
that a powerful man meaning Mountain our
derailed your career I know that in this
crazy business of ours you know it's
their sandbox by that I mean management
they get to decide who plays and it
happen it can happen to all of us at any
time that we lose our jobs but in your
particular case in the court of public
opinion many people thought that Matt
Lauer was behind you leaving The Today
Show I'd like to know what you feel
about that we've never talked about this
and I've always wondered wondered your
your last day was very emotional it was
very difficult for you clearly and I
don't want to upset you here again
either oh dude I'm not gonna start
crying
he was behind behind you know you should
ask someone else I'm not the one to ask
about that you're the only one has no no
because I I don't know what was all
behind it I do know that it hurt like
hell it wasn't a fun moment I've learned
a great deal about myself I really at
this point let it go I've just let it go
and I and I and I think that it's time
to it's been years and I want to sort of
really move on from that I mean it's
it's a it's a you know at this point I'm
thinking Hakuna Matata you know it's
just sort of over but no I think I think
that I think that the real question in
my view is what are we going to do with
all of this anger and it's not just
obviously about where I used to work
it's not about where you're now working
but it's about the problem that's
pervasive across industries in
workplaces across America and this is
actually the issue and the question is
ultimately what are we going to do about
it
and I wonder if we if we keep focusing
only on these individual scandals if
we're actually going to move off of that
foot into creating something better in
the future though each of the personal
stories add to this new conversation you
tweeted me to in October what did you
mean what was well I think I meant what
I just said which is you know
sorry job it is about you know the idea
that I don't know a single woman I don't
know a single woman who has not endured
some form of sexual harassment and and
many women have endured workplace sexual
harassment it's happened to me in
multiple jobs and and it and it is a way
of sidelining women you know and it's
ultimately not only bad for the women
it's bad for the companies and it's bad
for our nation because it's a limiting
of people and and really ultimately also
we should be talking about the victims
we're talking about the scandal the
scandals can that what about the victims
what are we going to do to remove the
stigma and the shame what are we going
to do to make sure these women work and
are not sidelined and prevented from
contributing to the greater good that we
all are trying to do what
we gonna do because you're talking about
it a power imbalance which goes as you
say outside of just sexual harassment it
goes to the structure of the place that
women are entering to and and what they
face when they come in so how does that
change that mean more women executives
does it mean taking women coming in how
does that chop solutely John I think
that until the glass ceiling is broken
until the balance of power is even and
remember that women are 1 to 1 in this
country and in many years
we are the majority right so until that
balance is reaction occurs then the
culture that we're talking about that
enables the diminishing of women will
continue and this is really what we need
to fix and this is why breaking the one
of the reasons why breaking the glass
ceiling is so well there are two women
anchoring the Today Show as you know
Savannah and Hoda and Savannah I think
called it one of those popular decisions
ever made did you ever think you would
see that two women at the table no I
think that's also overdue I mean as you
well know many of the viewers of the
morning broadcast now are women it's
overwhelmingly women and for the idea
that women are involved speaking to
women is actually an overdue idea so so
absolutely I think it's a good idea all
right and one thing and you said it hurt
like hell you learned a lot about
yourself what's the one thing you
learned about yourself that you want us
to know about you now well about me
maybe not so much but about all of us so
that when we open our arms wide to life
all the good and the bad if we can just
open ourselves wide to it and embrace it
we can learn we need to learn and we can
go on and and become better people and I
hope that I've done that and so that's I
think Nora said it best when she said
your much-anticipated return a lot of
people love and care about you and all
had your back then you're gonna stay for
8:30 a half-hour yes didn't talk about
my new show project actually here just
worked out anything good what'd you do
bad well I'm just gonna tell these
stories yeah but we will see Ann Curry
back here in our next hour to talk about
her new show on PBS it's called
we'll meet again